in Russia it is the old world and beefs
are settled in a very old world way
like blowing your plane out of the sky
or you get shot in the face people in
Russia you know uh leaders of opposition
parties people that have challenged uh
Putin journalists uh people they get
shot in the face there
it's an old system there's no route to
redemption in that country the way that
there is in America you cannot go host
The View
Rosie O'Donnell like you know what I
mean it's like you you have a fixed
amount of possibilities in Russia in the
old world of how it's going to work
you're going to be rich you're going to
be dead
those are the two possibilities in that
Mafia That's Mafia Mafia rules
rich or dead
it's Mafia rules in America we got oh
man do we got options
we got you think you're rich you're
famous you're famous and not rich you're
both you're dead half dead you've come
back
you got a thing going on with [__] uh
Netflix you have a podcast you were a
mob rat now you got a podcast you're
back out with all the guys you're ratted
on the mafia everybody's on a podcast
reading ads for blue chill because it's
still the greatest country in the world
that doesn't happen over there that's
not the case if you're a rat it's over
there
because they don't have the monetization
they don't know how to make money off
people they would otherwise kill like we
do
in Russia you just got to kill the
people that bother you just gotta kill
them
in America you can kind of let them [__]
around
late last week imprisoned Russian
opposition leader Alexi navalny was
handed a harsh judgment
after a court hit him with a 19-year
sentence in a penal colony he was sent
immediately to a punishment cell
it was a stark contrast to the fate of
Uganda against the person who's writing
this isn't aware that they're talking
about Russia they think they're talking
about America and the reason that I knew
he was in trouble get the photo up of
the guy taking the selfie with him when
he was leaving Russia look at this
they're doing it for the gram he doesn't
get it pregosian doesn't get it he
signed his death Lauren when he did that
little March that he was doing at
rastavandan and then on the way to
Moscow he fired on military helicopters
and killed Russian servicemen he can't
not be killed Putin would have no
credibility he was always going to be
killed every dummy in the Press Corps
over here from the Atlantic to New York
Times well no this is interesting
Putin's uh it's the real like uh you
know pretty embarrassing that this
happened and this guy's running around
it's like no he's not going to be killed
the next day
but this was pretty soon this was pretty
good and I saw that photo I said [__]
he's dead he's dead he's dead
people are taking selfies with him he
thinks he's in America he thinks he's an
American he thinks he's going to get an
agent
look at the pictures of them smiling
with the people he thinks CAA is gonna
sign him
thinks there's another way out because
the internet's powerful and I'm sure the
CIA and all these people are giving him
feeding him all kinds of crap like no no
you come over here and we'll look the
other way you know you you know there's
probably something for you to do you
know he wants very much he likes Fame
he's kind of delighting in it there's a
guy that was cutting heads off he was a
warlord to get the other photo where
he's like yeah there he is he's happy
he's bullied this was a guy who was a
few uh 48 hours before this photo he was
trying to overthrow the government of
Russia which didn't work because people
in Russia go no no no no it's the mafia
we're all getting paid we're it's like
we're we're in the it's a We're In
Cahoots here we're in cahoots and said
it's a whole what are you doing he's
like the people have been lied to and
everyone's going yeah we know we're La
we're lying to that what do you what do
you think you're gonna come in when you
think you're you're gonna come in here
on some like white knight White Horse
Ride in tell everybody and they know
he's a warlord it's a corrupt world off
this isn't Thomas Jefferson and I know
Thomas Jefferson wasn't Thomas Jefferson
don't bother me with that but my point
is that they all know this guy they know
him
did the warlord is cutting people's
heads off it's going to come in and no
they're all being they're enriched by
the Putin regime
and they're going dude he thinks he's
going to get support from all these guys
because some of them probably don't like
the Ukraine war some of them are like
it's [__] our money up but they know
that the reality is
they they've got all their money with
Putin they've got all their eggs in that
basket so he finds out
they're not coming over to him
he's not going to go whack the dawn in
front of everybody it's not gonna work
so then he's like
[__]
he goes well we're not okay sorry
I made my point he did this thing he did
this like about face where he goes hey
I made my point uh you know I killed a
few Russian servicemen by the way that's
not forgivable none of it's forgivable
to Putin right it's not really so he
then reverses course and the leader of
Belarus goes he'll come to Belarus and
then I saw these photos and he's leaving
and he's doing the celebrity thing or
maybe that's when he arrived in Belarus
I don't know but he's taking selfies
with people and he's smiling and he's
happy and I'm going
he doesn't understand
his fate or if he does he did a great
job disguising it
but I think he got a little in his
feelings as people would say and he
started to believe his own myth and he
started thinking like I just [__]
smacked one of the most powerful men in
the world in the face and he did nothing
and now everybody's taking selfies with
me everybody loves me I'm fine I'm back
I'm in
but unlike America you can't go host
Miss Universe again which Donald could
have
and I'm not saying there I'm not
equating them I'm just saying in terms
of the paths to Redemption there aren't
any in Russia you it you just live and
die
by what you did not so much what you can
do
so pregosian takes all these photos and
here's this article that shows kind of
the misunderstanding of that it was a
stark contrary to the fate of you
getting pagosian the head of the Russian
mercenary group Wagner back in June
pagosian led the abortive Mutiny that
presented the biggest challenge to
Russian Vladimir Putin in over two
decades of rule while percocian's troops
stopped short of Moscow
a furious Putin said in a televised
speech that those on the quote path of
treason would face punishment almost two
months later in the case of the Wagner
Chief this simply hasn't happened
and then they did Cover themselves they
go clearly the price for confronting
Putin is not fixed perhaps more
surprisingly hasn't even kept a low
profile since the tune up or I think
what was weird is that this guy didn't
just disappear
okay
he didn't just disappear he came back
to Russia
and he's like taking photos with people
you know it's crazy you gotta just he
should have just went to Africa they
still would have killed him they still
would have killed him
but he might have bought himself a
little time if he went to Africa like
he's in Russia
it's crazy
while subscribers to his telegram
telegram Channel have become accustomed
to seeing him in camouflage in tactical
gear pagosian was spotted in a polo
shirt and mom jeans cutting a seemingly
more mild manner figure Than A month's
Pat yeah he's got a thought
are you nuts
by the way he
he got like really famous for that and
now he's losing his mind he's doing Glam
shots in Saint Petersburg in a in a polo
shirt like I'm a famous guy now on the
world stage
sorry I tried to overthrow the
government but listen
there's got to be equity in my brand no
isn't there equity in this brand
it's it's old rules there and I knew he
was gonna get I didn't know how he was
gonna get it
but I knew he was gonna get it was no
question but all these articles were
coming out in the American Press which I
understand they're just writing articles
to try to you know piss Putin off and
whatever make it seem like he has no
control over the country and again I'm
not I'm not like Bros with Vladimir put
one must say that now because people
can't listen with the critical thought
it's no longer a faculty that most
people in this country possess
um somebody tried to debate this with me
on Instagram and I never respond but I
started responding with voice memos to
someone and then eventually they were
just like well I don't really have all
the fat it's like no one has all the
facts but this this idea that you have
to come out and tell people you know
you're not uh you don't adore
Vladimir Putin to just call a spade a
spade and say
up is up and down is most likely down
and I knew that this guy probably wasn't
get away with it so let us fast forward
but again you could see how out of his
mind he is in the polo shirt look at
this photo he's out of his mind
he was he was a week away from going
back to being a chef that's how crazy he
went he was on a level of crazy where he
was going to start food blogging soon
like he was gonna be start he would he's
trying to get unchopped like he was
trying to go backwards to when he was
the chef he was like nonetheless forget
about the clue forget about you I lobbed
a few heads off bygones everyone does I
shot a few a rushed into planes out of
the air not a big deal let's go back to
my real passion food let's go back to my
real passion like there's you know in
his crazy head I know in his crazy head
because I met a lot of people that are
really famous not like my level of fan
which is like who cares I'm talking
about people that are genuinely like
they pop to get really really famous and
it is an interesting thing that happens
in your head
where the possibilities seem endless
because the people that are employed to
work with you their job is to make the
possibilities seem endless so once
you've gotten some level of Fame people
they sit around you in Office Buildings
in Los Angeles and go you know you you
know you could you could do the Olympics
have you trained at all for the Olympics
no I know you're 40 and fat but there's
got to be what about curling there's got
to be an event that you could get in and
even if you don't Place top three it's
such great there's so many eyeballs
there'll be so many eyeballs on you
doing the Olympic like their job is not
to live in reality their job is to make
you feel like anything you ever wanted
to do not only is possible but it's a
good idea it's a great idea
you want to make a song having never
sang and have never had any musical to
do it
do it Studio's ready you will be in the
studio tomorrow Taylor Swift if she
wants to act she can act she can do
anything she wants no one will tell if
Taylor Swift wanted to go and into
Russia and do what Wagner did there
would be people going you know I think
we can do it I think we can do because
no one will tell her no she is the most
powerful person on in this country right
now because she's made a billion dollars
and when you make a billion dollars in
the summer
I can't even get people in Charlotte
Charlotte North Carolina don't [__]
me I've said horrible things about you
and I'll continue to but buy the tickets
don't start September what 15th my point
is Taylor Swift's made a billion when
you make a billion dollars in a summer
the person who tells you no will be
thrown out of a window they will you
will never hear the word no anything she
wants to do if she wants to like perform
on a on if she wants to take a 747 out
there I do like concert in the sky and
parachute it like no one will tell her
no
because she made a billion dollars on a
tour in the summer this is this is you
know when you get that big when you're
that big and pregosian did the Russian
version of that he tried to take over
Moscow he tried to beat the Kremlin that
is the difference of the two countries
in America our biggest star is Taylor
Swift in Russia it was evgeny pagosian
because he tried to topple the Kremlin
and nothing gets more press in Russia
than a war sure they have pop stars they
have people that try to do it they come
back
come on and they're all you know they're
drunk and they're in a club and it works
you know everybody's trying to get laid
and you can listen to that crap for a
while you know
but they don't do what we do they do War
they do Coos so pregosian's the guy like
damn
but our Goshen is is the person who made
a billion dollars selling white girl
nostalgia in the summer Taylor Swift God
love her
again people say to me why don't you
like her good no no she's great I just
again I wasn't around I was doing Coco
selling mortgages it wasn't for me it
wasn't for me